صباح تقول في نهايه صباح الخير 2020 سهام
همم اقول بانه عام مضى بخيره وشره ونتمنى
ان العام المقبل يكون عام مليء بالاحداث
الجميله
لمنطقتنا وعلمنا العرب والعالم باجمع هذا
العام مر على السعوديه باحداث كثيره
ومختلفه للغايه ابرز الاحداث كان رفع
وزاره الداخليه السعوديه في شهر يونيو
الماضي
لاجراءات الاحترازيه لكوفيد نايتين فايروس
كرونا والذي كان سبب كبير لسعاده
السعوديين والمقيمين بعد شهور طويله
للاجراءات الاحترازيه المشدده ايضا في 25
يونيو من عام 20 22
كشفه ولي العهد السعودي عن المخططات
والتصاميم الاوليه لمدينه ذا لاين في
اليوم هذه المدينه الحالم وفي شمال غرب
السعوديه ايضا السعوديه قدمت للعالم
النسخه الثانيه من مبادره الشرق الاوسط
الاخضر هذه مبادره الضخمه لالغايه تهدف
للزراعه ملايين العشار في منطقتنا ايضا
كان هناك عده فعاليات رياضيه وفنيه موسم
الرياض بدا بحله جديده ومناطق جديده
ابرزها بوليفارد ورد ايضا كان هناك مهرجان
البحر الاحمر للسينما ايضا كان هناك موسم
الدرعيه بطوله
التنس الدوليه ايضا بطوله الجولف الدوليه
وغيرها من الفعاليات الفنيه الحفلات
الموسيقيه مثل بيس الذي شهد حضور اشهر
الدجاج العالميين ايضا ابرز الحدث المهم
وهو فوز المنتخب السعودي على نظيره
الارجنتيني في نسخه كاس العالم في قطر
والج الشهيره التي اصبحت ايقونه لكاس
العالم ورز ميسي
[موسيقى]
شكرا جزيلا عبد الرحمن شكرا لك في اخر طله
لك في صباح العربيه هذه السنه شكرا لك
نورتنا السنه كلها عبد الرحمن
[موسيقى]